i guess early in your career you
understudied peter o'toole's part in the
long the short and the tall is that
right yeah
we were all unknown actors in the 60s
and peter got this lead in this play the
long and short at all
some of the other people who were in it
were
robert shaw terrence stamp richard
harris
um which may sound all like a lot of
people who became famous but an artifact
was a lot of drunks that's it
now you got yeah you guys were serious
serious drinkers yeah in those days the
british british actors were all drunks
we we had heroes
and our heroes were people like trevor
howard and people like that and so we
thought to be a great actor you had to
be
be a drunk
and so we all became drunks uh and uh um
o'toole
i mean o'toole was a notorious drunk and
so was i
um but with the you know something did
you make you really made a conscious
decision i'm just gonna for the love of
my question i'm gonna drink that jack
daniels yeah we got the idea in our
heads you see i had read
that alcohol destroys inhibition cells
in the brain
and so one of the great enemies of the
actor obviously is inhibition i mean
when you go to drama school they make
you do stupid things that just so you
don't make a fool of yourself and you
don't care like i'm doing now exactly
you see i don't care
and
so we all used to drink to get rid of
our inhibitions and but with o'toole i
mean he really drank a lot i was his
understudy and my job was uh getting the
booze in you know
but it never i didn't know that's what
an understudy did no i didn't until i
got a job i'd never been an understudy i
was just a drunk actor and then i was
then i had to stay sober to count to
change
we need to go and buy the booze sure
yeah so it got me off the booze a little
bit because i had a job
and um
so
but
it never destroyed peter's perform it
never we never let it interfere with the
performance at all because peter was
brilliant he became a massive star
overnight in that and i took over from
him he went off to do launch of arabia i
took over from him and then that helped
me along my way as well but oh too i
remember o'toole once said saturday
night we finished the show there's no
show sunday so saturday night he said
let's go out and do this and that
and
the next thing i know
i wake up and it's daylight
and
i'm lying next to o'toole both of us
fully clothed in a strange bed
maybe he told the press maybe it wasn't
your wife
so
he
i shook him and he said
what time is it
and i said well it's uh
seven o'clock in the evening so i said
all right we we better get home you know
there's seven o'clock sunday evening he
said i missed lunch and
and then this girl came in
and she said you know it's seven o'clock
and then o'toole said wait a minute he
said i've done this before
he said you don't know this michael he
said to the girl what day is it
and she said monday
and he said
the curtain goes up at eight and we
didn't even know where we were and i
never found out what happened to sunday
[Laughter]
and he couldn't count me wow
that was but that was that was the time
i get the sense that that was in the
early 60s now it's yeah you see we
didn't have any drugs
you see alcohol was our drugs uh and so
uh but uh
so that's that's what we used to use to
to get rid of all our frustrations and
everything so we didn't we didn't do
drugs
i'm saying do drugs like i know what
it's all about i never had any drugs you
know you can't do drugs and drink
alcohol at the same time but also you
didn't get arrested for doing alcohol
you know if but i never saw any drugs in
those days in the 60s in the late 60s it
started the drugs started to come in
but i was so fun to drink by then i
didn't care
well tell us about this is uh you're
working on a for nbc you've done a
program i guess it's uh it's it's a
special it's it's the the relationship
of um stalin and churchill and uh
roosevelt in the war and really the way
uh the whole of europe was carved up
after the war and the way they ran the
war i play stalin and uh bob huskins
plays churchill and john lithgow plays
roosevelt okay and uh ed begley jr plays
his assistant harry hopkins now this is
i guess we have a clip we need to do
anything for this clip yeah uh um
this is i think basically to describe it
is just to give you an example of the
sort
all the dialogue in this is no dialogue
written by the writer
all of it is absolutely true dialogue
taken from transcripts recordings
uh and
shorthand notes stalin roosevelt
churchill
and this is a typical example of the way
that stalin would threaten in a nice way
when he wasn't getting his own way all
right let's take a look at this clip
yeah
the prime minister
uh
arises late in the morning don't you
winston
yes and then
works hard until mid-afternoon sleeps
before dinner
and then he's up half the night talking
what's your schedule
i work until five in the morning
so do all my admirals and
asleep until 10 in the morning
not so easy alive
i do it seven days a week
small birds
better be careful where they sing
wow
that's a
that's a very uh
that's a good start i mean when i heard
you were playing stars when i actually
saw the i saw the clip this afternoon
it's uh that's a great star and it's a
very he's a menacing character yeah he
is very much but i know when when people
i'd people say to me you know what are
you doing i said i'm doing this thing
with churchill and stalin and they said
who are you playing i say stalin
and they look at me and i go yeah yeah
[Laughter]
who's playing uh churchill i said bob
hoskins
and the next question is always is it a
comedy
because if you look at me you don't say
we've got to get we got to cast stalin
find michael caine we can't do it
he's a ringer for stalin
stalin was five feet two with black hair
and brown arms i'm six feet two with
blonde hair and blue eyes wow
have they ever thought about doing it as
a comedy with music and
they will they they will they will
that's next season on cbs all right well
listen uh oh he's getting a man he's
getting them in oh no no no listen that
actually looks good people should look
for that's world war ii when lions
roared is on tuesday may 19th from 8 to
10 and part 2 airs wednesday may 20th
it was really great talking to you it
was really nice
we've never met before no we haven't
it's nice to see you thank you
thanks for michael kane everybody